[Music]
hi everybody my name is Colton Ogden
this is G d50 lecture 1 and today we'll
be covering flappy bird so last year we
are in last week sorry we covered pong
which was just you know basic shapes and
colors today will actually be diving
into sprites as we can see here we got
some pipes and a bird and we're covering
a few other concepts such as gravity and
more today the topics that we'll be
covering are in a nutshell images and
sprites as I just said so loading images
from memory from our hard drive and
actually drawing them to the screen
instead of just you know rectangles and
whatnot we'll be covering infinite
scrolling so seeing things like and if
you if you've played the game pipes are
infinitely going from right to left how
to actually get that going infinitely so
that we're not using up also infinite
memory we'll be discussing how games and
in the similar vein are illusions in the
sense that a lot of the perceived
vastness and perceived complexity of
games is often just due to camera
trickery and more because of limited
hardware will be covering procedural
generation which ties also into infinite
scrolling procedures generation is a
topic that I am actually very interested
in and will be touching on it throughout
the course in several locations but in
the Kansai area in the context of
today's lecture we'll be using it for
the pipes because the pipes they spawn
from right to left and flappy bird is
your infinitely going through the level
but they can spawn at various Heights
and the gaps are shifting as a result of
that therefore creating this sort of
infinite level we'll be talking more in
detail on state machines so last week we
covered state machines in a very
abstract sense we used it just basically
a string as a variable and then used if
conditions today we'll be actually using
a state machine class replete with
various methods that allow us to
transition in and out of these states
very cleanly and allow us to break out
all of this logic that we previously had
in our update and render functions and
then put them separately into their own
state classes and then lastly we'll also
be touching on mouse input and a point
that I forgot to mention here whoops is
also Matt will be talking about music
which is just basically sound which we
did last week but we'll add that as a
polishing touch if you guys want
download the demo code we have a repo up
right now on github slash games 50/50
bird it's our take on flappy bird a
couple of things I've been asked a
couple of times whether we have reading
materials for the course and there are
no formal reading materials but there
are a couple of resources that I really
enjoyed reading especially as I was
getting more into Lua and love 2d they
are two books one is an online book
actually they're both online books but
the latter of which has a physical form
as well the four first of these is how
to make an RPG by Dan Schuler which is
actually completely written in Lua he
uses a custom game engine very similar
to love 2d but it's hand written by him
but a lot of the same ideas apply and
it's a great opportunity it's how I cut
my teeth on Lua and I would encourage
you to take a look at that if that's
something you're interested in or if you
like RPGs and then also game programming
patterns by Robert Nystrom is a very
great general-purpose game development
book that talks about a lot of these
sort of more abstract high-level
concepts with large-scale game
development but yeah beyond that no
formal reading those aren't formal
reading either those are just if you're
curious and you want to read some
resources that I found very interesting
feel free to do so today's goal is to
implement what looks like this this is a
this is our version of flappy bird we
didn't use the same exact sprites for
copyright purposes but we note that we
have a bird in the middle of the screen
this bird on click or on spacebar will
jump up and down and your goal is to
prevent the bird from touching either
the pipes or the ground itself and every
time you make it past a pair of pipes
you will score a point as soon as you
touch a pipe or hit the ground game is
over and that's that so today we'll be
covering I'll doing a little bit more
live coding so the very first example
that I want to cover is the day zero
update for flappy bird and a important
function that is going to be probably
the most noticeable the most visibly
obvious function we'll be using
throughout this lecture is love graphics
that new image which takes a path this
function all it does is load a image
file from your disk you specify it as a
string and you can then use it as an
object and draw anywhere you want at an
XY coordinate and we'll see this in
practice here so I'm going to go ahead
if
looking in the repo all of these
examples are covered zero through 12 I'm
going to start from scratch and a new
folder that I've created I'm going to
create a brand new main.lua
completely fresh and first thing i want
to do is because we are going to use a
virtual resolution just like we did last
week so that we have a more retro
aesthetic I'm going to go ahead and
require the push library so push equals
require push just like that
I've pre put push Lua into this
directory it will just load by default
in the same directory the current
working directory of your script when
you run love the next thing I'm gonna do
I'm gonna define some constants so
window width should be 1280 and the
window height is gonna be 720 those are
our physical window dimensions but then
we also need a virtual width and we're
going to use 512 by 288 this is a
resolution that I found worked pretty
well for the assets we'll be using today
but you can make this most anything you
want to as long as it's somewhat in that
range it is a sixteen by nine resolution
as well so that it fits comfortably on
modern white screen a sixteen by nine
monitors what we're gonna do is the
first goal that we have today is to sort
of draw two images to the screen we want
a foreground and a background because
notice if we go back to the slides we
can see in the very background we have a
sort of he'll landscape and then on the
bottom we have a ground and they're the
two of those are going to eventually
scroll at different rates it's code we
called parallax scrolling but just for
our very first example we have something
very basic I just wanna draw two images
to the screen so we're gonna go ahead
and do that here by setting a local
variable remember local means that it's
just defined to the scope that it's in
rather than being global which means we
cannot access this variable outside of
this file local background gets loved
dot graphics
new image the function that we just
talked about let me go ahead and hide
this inspector here so we can have more
room to code and then it's just going to
take a string so background dot PNG and
I realize I actually didn't include
those files in the directory so I'm
going to need to do that as well
same thing for the ground exact
function love dog graphics at new image
except ground ing and before I forget
let's go ahead and do that right now
I have the files here ground and
background and copy those from the repo
the distro repo into my bird zero
directory that I'm currently developing
in right now and so as soon as we're
done with that we're going to go ahead
and we're going to define love load
which is the function love duty calls at
the beginning of your program execution
in there because we don't want these
images to look blurry when they get
loaded and up scaled we want to go ahead
and set our default filters in nearest
on min and mag which means on upscale
and downscale apply nearest-neighbor
filtering which means no blurriness no
interpolation of the pixels and then one
thing that is just a small little touch
love that window dot set title fifty
bird because is GD fifty and then we're
gonna go ahead and setup our screen here
with our virtual width virtual height
window width window Heights it's getting
a bit long and then it takes in the
table recall tables just take in keys
like so unlike in python where you might
use a colon we use an equal sign in love
or in Lua I should say resizable to true
and that is the end of our load function
now does anybody recall how we if we
want to resize so notice I said
resizable to true do we know how we want
how we can send a message to push to
resize our screen for us so love 2d
defines a function called love resize
which takes in a width and a height and
in there all we're going to do is defer
that call to push we call the exact same
function on push it takes a width and a
height and that will take care of
dynamically re scaling the canvas it
uses internally it renders to a texture
and it's going to render to the texture
that we set as their virtual width and a
virtual height and it's going to scale
it to fit our screen and it needs to
know our physical screen domain
so that it can actually properly scale
that internal canvas appropriately does
anybody remember the function that we
use to get input from the user
so function dot love dot key pressed
recall takes in a key love is going to
call this automatically every time we
press a key and that's going to be we're
going to have access to that key and we
can do any sort of logic that we want on
that key or using that key and we're
just going to call love daddy that quit
because I don't like to press command Q
or click the red X I just want to hit
escape be done with it and then what's
our render what's love's render function
called so I love draw so called love top
draw and then because we're using push
does anybody remember what we need to
actually do to get pushed to render our
screen to a virtual resolution so rip
call that there's actually two ways we
can do it we can call push start and
push finish which we didn't cover last
week or we can call and that's actually
the new diff like sort of de facto way
to do it or we can do push apply start
which is the deprecated way to do it but
starting from here on out we're just
gonna call push start and push finish
and then last we have our images we've
allocated them as objects up here we
have a background and a ground all we
need to do now is just draw them to the
screen so this is a new function or it's
actually it's not a new function it is a
new function actually love dog graphics
dot rectangles we'll use last week for
all of the draw calls in this case we
want to draw a graph a image object a
texture object that we have in memory so
we're gonna call love graphics draw and
it takes a drawable which means anything
that love has defined as something that
can be drawn in this case images are
drawables they can be drawn and they can
be drawn at any given position that you
specify so if we wanted to draw it at
the top left corner we would just say
love that graphics top background at 0 0
and it has that effect and we're going
to the exact same thing with our ground
the only difference being that obviously
we don't want to draw at the top-left
corner
we want to draw at the bottom of the
screen so just call virtual height minus
16 which happens to be the height of our
image so if you run this I'm going to go
ahead and make sure I'm in the right
directory not in the right directory so
I'm going to go into a directory I wrote
50 bird scratch go into birds 0 and if I
run this I should theoretically have
just two images layered on top of each
other which I do not
so let me assure that it gets saved
remember to always save your work and
there we go so all we're doing now it's
it looks infinitely better than last
week already but it's very simple very
few lines of code all the effort that
we've put into it has been in our sprite
editor of choice and you can use most
any application you want to do this sort
of stuff I use a program called a sprite
I like a lot but you can do this in [ __ ]
which is free you could do it in
Photoshop you could do it in Microsoft
Paint if you wanted to Godspeed if you
do but yeah so that's that's as simple
as it is just to draw images to the
screen so we've already made quite a lot
of progress in a very short period of
time in terms of the visual aspect of
our game but it's not interesting to
look at beyond the initial sort of
honeymoon period of now we have colors
on the screen we want to actually get
scrolling because the game recall is a
scrolling game and actually would
anybody be willing to volunteer to come
up and play flappy bird just so we can
see it live on the stage David you want
to come up and play Oh someone volunteer
Stephen you want to come up and play
thank you for volunteering
I'm guarantee you're better at this game
than I am so I'm going to go ahead and
CD into bird bird 12 in the directory
which is the final version of the game
complete so I'm going to go ahead hit
enter so already we can see the parallax
scrolling that I referred to before
which is the floor and the background
are scrolling at different rates and
we'll see this very shortly in the next
example we have a prompt we have text
we've already used this before with a
font so go ahead if you press ENTER
you're gonna get a countdown so space is
to jump so we have our bird jumping in
the middle of the screen we have a score
at the top goal is to avoid in the pipes
oh that's for 1 we'll try again so it
keeps track of his position and every
time he gets past the right edge of a
pair of pipes as you can see that's when
you get the point so if you recall from
last week
what do we think is what what's what's
what's detecting the collision-free
remember last request a term maybe
remember access to lines bound AABB
collision detection access to line
bounding boxes the same thing that we
did with long except now we're doing it
we have graphics but this is same same
as that concept which is using
rectangles and when we run one rectangle
overlaps with another rectangle we
trigger death so one last iteration I
think it will play try one more time go
ahead I'll give it a shot
all right I'm gonna lose on purpose okay
here we go so to be to be unfair I got
plenty of practice while developing this
but we'll see if that actually holds
true here
all right so notice also the pipes
there's there the procedure generation
and I oh I lost three points let me
explain a little bit more oh I guess
well you want more iteration but the
pipes themselves every time we start
they're spawning at a different location
this is procedural generation on them
pretty much the most simplest way
possible and notice that the pipes are
shifting gradually so this is sort of
like the makeup of our level and it's
generating bit by bit due to some simple
algorithm that we have that just says
hey spawn of the pipe gear shift it by
some amount and this very simple
approach allows us to have an infinite
level over and over again it's very
efficient we only ever have as many
pipes on the screen and as we'll see you
soon we only have as many pipes in
memory as we can see on the screen at
one time despite the fact that this
level could theoretically go on
infinitely and so it's very
cost-efficient so bird one is the
example it's the parallax update so
parallax scrolling is an important
concept in 2d and also 3d but 2d game
development it refers to the illusion of
movement given to two frames of
reference that are that moving at
different rates so if you're driving on
the highway and you see a fence next to
you
and you see mountains in the distance
you're observing parallax scroll by
seeing how fast the fence moves relative
to the mountains the mountains are going
to move a lots more slowly than the
fence is right
next to you and we accomplished the same
exact illusion in our game by referee by
using this sort of graphical illusion
and so I'm going to go ahead in my
directory here in bird one which is a
unpopulated direct woods it's populated
with the contents of birds zero the
complete contents of bird zero you're
the version that you'll see will have
all of the code but I'm going to go
ahead and if we run bird zero in that
directory so I think right now I'm still
in the full distro so let me go ahead go
into 50 Birds scratch again clips where
am I
and then I'm gonna go into bird one and
run it and I get the exact same image
that we had last time so everything is
there from before just two images
nothing moving no parallax that we can
observe I'm going to go ahead and start
implementing the basics of this parallax
so if I go ahead in my main so I'm going
to go down here to where we have our
background so we need a couple of new
things so along with our background
image we need to keep track of how much
it's scrolled because we're gonna need
to start drawing this image to the
screen but if we're gonna scroll it that
means that we need to shift its X offset
we need to instead of drawing it at zero
zero if we want it to scroll we have to
draw it at some negative value instead
over time this will have the effect of
it moving right to left so I'm going to
go ahead and keep track of a I'm gonna
use a variable to keep track of this
scroll amount for both of these images
and we're going to call them background
scrolling ground scroll and stuff into
zero so this is gonna have the effect of
no X offset so I could use this variable
right now in this draw call down here
which I'm actually going to do I'm gonna
go ahead and go to I'm justify the bit
as correct
I'm gonna go ahead and set that to
negative background scroll oops and here
I'm gonna set this to negative ground
scroll so this is not going to change
anything yet it's gonna be the exact
same thing because they're both zero
they were zero before but we're going to
change them over time and in order to do
this I'm gonna go ahead and go into our
up here one thing before you before we
do that actually we need to set a speed
for this there's gonna happen over time
but since they need to occur at
different rates the background needs to
go at a slower rate than the foreground
so that we do get this parallax effect
we need to separate speed variables
generally the norm for something that is
not going to change is to write it in
caps with underscores this is constant
notation this is frequently seen in most
programming languages we'll use it here
I'm going to set a variable called
background scroll speed and I'm just
gonna set that to 30 I'm going to the
same thing ground scroll speed does this
need to be higher or lower than the
background scroll speed the ground is
going to move the so the background
needs to move slower than the ground
does so this is gonna be higher so we're
just gonna set it to 60 you can set to
whatever you want to get the effect that
you want but this will already be quite
noticeable the ground is gonna move
twice as fast as the background and so
what we're gonna do also is if we just
so what what's gonna happen if we just
let our image scroll infinitely what's
gonna happen at a certain point it's
gonna run out of image so how do we fix
this problem loop it exactly so we're
gonna go ahead and set a looping point
so another constant background looping
point and we're gonna set this to 4 13
which you kind of have to look at your
image and determine you you sort of have
to set your images up if you want to
achieve this effect by having them be a
looping image so have either two copies
of the exact same thing that's their
screen width or just copy the same chunk
over and over again there's many ways to
do it in this case the looping point of
the image of our background is 4 13 on
the x-axis so we're gonna set that to 4
13 and then we're going to go ahead the
next step is we actually have to start
changing the value so in our update
function which is where this is going to
happen
I'm going to go ahead and define love
that update which we call love 2d will
call for you but you must define it
yourself I'm going to go ahead and set
background scroll to
so what this is gonna do background
scroll gets background scroll to itself
plus the speed we set before times Delta
time so it stays framerate independent
that will have the effect of adding the
speed to our image but we need to reset
it we need to actually perform the reset
and to do that we'll just be using
modulus which recall from languages like
C simply divides basically sets that
value to the remainder of that division
so in this case so 10 modulo 5 would be
0 but 10 modulo 9 would be 1 effectively
because we have 0 left over once we
divide 10 by 5 we have 1 left over once
we divide 10 by 9 so I apologize if that
concept is not new but we're going to do
the same exact thing for our ground
only we're going to modulo by the ground
or of our virtual width in this case I
did not set a looping point I do in
later examples but the our ground image
is very it's consistent enough such that
you don't even notice it when it loops
without using a with just without just
using the virtual width so we're gonna
use the virtual within that case it's
very patterned and very small and aside
from that yeah we already have the off
the background scrolls here in our
render air draw functions so when we run
this code we should theoretically have
scrolling background they do at least
twice the width yes there's ways you
could effectively tile your image and do
it that way to save memory on on texture
size if you have like maybe something
that's a quarter of the screen size that
you want to loop over and over again you
don't want to have that as one big image
you'll just draw four copies of that
image to fill your screen and then just
shift all of them maybe five actually so
you have a little bit beyond the edge of
the screen and then just put all of them
back to zero
exactly
so like we could we could actually I
could show you right now what that'll
look like so if we just take out the
looping point here or we set it to some
like value that's completely inaccurate
like 270 and then we run it after a
while should just cut yep right there
no the image is so wide that it always
will fill the screen even after it's
been set back to even after it's gone
past the looping point I forget how
large the texture is it is yeah 11:57
pixels wide so it's more than twice the
screen width actually I think it is
exactly twice the screen width no it's
not exactly I just guys but it's more
than twice the screen width so that when
the amount the 413 pixels has elapsed
it's still plenty past the right edge of
the screen and the looping part it'll be
the exact same appearance on the texture
but it's completely been shifted back to
the right so that zero zero is now at
zero the zero zero of our image is now
at zero zero in our screen space it's
just taking it your images here moving
and then just instantly back to the
beginning and then moving back to it
that's the setting it back to zero or
however technically how many pixels has
gone past the edge of the screen because
using modulo yep it's a translation it's
an instant translation it takes place
over one frame so you don't notice that
your human eye can't see it because it
literally happens in one frame and at
the exact the the image data is the
exact same at those two points because
we have a texture we've pre created a
texture that has the exact same data so
that you have that effect you have to
have a texture that allows you to do
this or smartly draw four of the same
images keep track of all four of them or
actually eight of them so that you can
move them to the left and then shift
them all back to the right
when we get to Super Mario Brothers
we'll be talking about a concept called
tile mapping which is where we take a
sprite sheet and then you basically chop
it up into pieces have a map in that
it's basically numerical so that a brick
is like 1 the value 1 and then you look
through this giant two-dimensional array
that you have and then go over it
iterate over it and then draw a tile
like give at an offset based on your
index into that map so it's a little bit
more complicated and you actually a lot
more memory efficient but slightly
different slightly different
implementations okay so we have parallax
rolling now
I want to take a moment to because we've
touched on we've sort of this is this is
a very sort of introductory way of
demonstrating that games are illusions
by using parallax scrolling we've all
we've done really is just set to things
to scroll different rates and this has
made us feel like we have depth in our
scene but all we're doing we have two
images we're scrolling them at different
rates but this is a common theme in game
development it's taking trying to devise
a scene that maybe is very elaborate but
doing it on very resource-intensive
devices like your iPhone or like you
know an old consoles like the Nintendo
64 these sort of illusions are all over
the place and a YouTube channel that I
that I recently found that I really like
is it's called the name of the channel
as she says but the actual show that
they have is called boundary break and
what they do is they take a camera that
it goes beyond what the game developers
allowed it to do which they basically
hack the game camera so you can see in
places where you weren't supposed to see
before and you can see a lot of really
cool trickery I'm about to show you a
couple of video clips but here's the
YouTube URL if you're curious to see the
exact video it's about thirty three
minute video it's on Zelda Ocarina of
Time for the n64 and I'm extracted a
couple of particularly noteworthy clips
that I thought were kinda
interesting and also humorous I'm gonna
go ahead and show the clip now so if we
could dim the lights I'll go ahead and
start this is a first example okay so
there's a lot to talk about with the
shop owners in the ocarina of time so
I'm gonna just condense it down to the
most interesting and the first one we're
gonna talk about is the bazaar shop
owner in Hyrule now in Majora's Mask
this very same character is actually
shown with legs but in our current time
he did not have those in fact he looks
extremely hilarious without his legs so
this is a do we do did anybody have an
instinct as to why they might have done
this this way
exactly and beyond that also just saving
on memory right like not having to load
a character model the vertices and
textures associated with it on a such a
memory constrained device like the n64 I
forget how many how much memory it had
like four megabytes of memory I think
less than that and so there are
obviously cutting however many corners
they could in this case by literally
using the illusion of looking at not the
illusion but just sort of like the fact
that you only could see over the counter
and sort of giving you the illusion that
there's a fully living talking
shopkeeper their bits just a half a
model and another example here is more
to show how Ocarina of Time used its
limited memory the n64 is limited memory
to give you the sense of being in a very
large level when you might not actually
have been so they could dim the lights
one more time I'll go ahead and show
this so this one was apparently a hot
suggestion yeah which is free camera on
Death Mountain including our friend big
Gore on the smoke halo looks sort of
weird against the black sky and here you
can see a Nintendo fooled us it's not
full Mountain only the cliff face is
actually rendered that's the path
leading towards the Fire Temple and if
we zoom out we can see the scale of the
whole map bigger than I thought it'd be
actually the battle musics not quite
fitting for an epic panning shot though
same idea here really just limited
memory space so let's load you know as
much as we could possibly ever see from
the perspective of the camera of link
and it's actually very similar to how I
guess people create stages in real life
to make you feel as if you're in a when
you go to a play feel like you're
actually in a scene but you know they've
clearly cut as many corners as possible
but it works in the game you can't tell
and that's very common in game
development and something if you're
trying to achieve a particularly grand
effect it's something to think about is
how can I make it seem like I'm doing
something but I'm actually not how can I
make it seem like I'm a bird flying
through an infinite series of levels but
I'm actually not we have a lot of sort
of more of that to show coming up soon
we have so so far we have our background
but we don't have the title character of
our game in the in this case 50 bird so
I'm going to go ahead and illustrate how
we can get a bird actually rendering on
the screen so I'm going to go ahead into
my bird 2 directory here that I've
created and note again bird 2 in your
directory if you've loaded the code is
going to have the complete
implementation but in main I'm going to
do a couple things so actually first
thing I'm going to do we're going to
notice that I've included actually I
haven't included the class file so I'm
going to do that right now so in bird 1
and herb so I'm going to take from bird
3 the class 2 I'm gonna go ahead and put
it into bird 2 because we're gonna make
a bird class we're called from last week
of classes just a way of taking several
variables that we might want to have had
disparate from one of their putting them
in together in a package putting
functions associated with those
variables together so that we can call
we we can sort of think of our world our
game world more abstractly and more
compartmentalized and cleaner so I'm
moving ahead and now I have in bird to
the class dot lua that's just the
library we're using to get classes in
love 2d and lua i'm going to go ahead
and i'm going to create a new file
this one's called bird lua so remember
the trend is for classes capitalized
them to differentiate them from
functions and variables this one I'm
gonna go ahead and just go ahead and use
my cheat sheet here college sheets are
sticking together okay so this bird
class is actually fairly simple recall
that all we have to do to create a class
is just use the class library the
capital C with the brackets there to
initialize it we're going to go ahead
and define our init function so every
class has an init function which
initializes the object that it's going
to refer to later in this case we're
going to need a few things so we're
going to need an image for our bird
because we want to draw to the screen
and so what we need to do same thing
that we did before love dog graphics add
a new image I'm going to go ahead and
hide this really fast and then bird dot
PNG simple easy we want the width and
the height of our bird so I'm going to
go ahead and set that to so every image
has a set of functions associated with
it that love implements for us the image
that we get back from love that graphics
new image is itself sort of a class
which has a function called get width so
this will allow us to achieve the width
dynamically of whatever class we
whatever image file we happen to
allocate and create an object from and
then we're going to go ahead and set our
X&Y because recall we have to draw it
somewhere we want to draw our bird in
the middle of the screen so we're going
to go ahead and just calculate this
based on our virtual width so we're
going to do virtual width divided by two
so it's halfway the mobile screen but
since it draws from the top left corner
we want to shift it to the left so we're
going to use our width that we just
instead we just initialized from the
image data and then we're going to call
it do a self dot width divided by two so
we're going to divide the width by two
shift that to the left on our x-axis
that's going to put us in the middle
horizontally vertically it's the exact
same thing
except we're using height instead of
whip and that's pretty much it except
for one last bit here we want to be able
to render our bird pretty important so
we're gonna do love graphics dot draw
our image and then at self dot X self
that way and so this is a all we really
need just to get a very simple sprite
onto the screen now it's not going to do
anything because this sort of lives in a
vacuum at the moment what we need to do
is in our main file we're gonna require
bird which is going to actually put it
into our allow us to use it in our code
we're going to create a local bird
variable we're just gonna call it bird
we're going to after that simply
render to the screen like that and if
all is done and well and if I'm in the
right directory did not work make sure
make sure you save your work again
oh did not require class my bed so also
we need to do this since we added that
to our directory and I did not include
the the bird PNG as well so I'm gonna go
ahead and do that I'm going to borrow
that from the next directory that should
be all we need to do and attempt to call
method render a nil value interesting
did I not save bird I did not save bird
there we go we did it so not
particularly interesting but it's sort
of you know we're making steps remember
to save your work is it we can see I do
not but we're making progress we have we
have our entity that we will control so
you know we have visually we have we're
getting very close but a lot of
important details are missing what
should be the next step do we think
how would we help exactly and we'll do
that with the help of a notion that's
common in platformers and a lot of games
really but gravity how do we how do we
think we can simulate gravity in the
context of 2d game development we could
do that certainly and that's effectively
what we will be doing we'll be using
something that we used last week which
was velocity Delta Y and applying that
velocity to our Birds Y frame-by-frame
and that will give it the illusion of
falling now falling at a constant rate
isn't accurate to what gravity actually
does what we want to do probably is some
gravity over and over again increment
our gravity by some sort of constant
value so that just like in real life
things fall faster and faster and then
we want to we want to add that to our Y
value so I'm going to go ahead and start
implementing that now in bird 3 wrong
repo so bird 3 we have everything that
we had from before except now I'm going
to go ahead and in main lua in our
update function this is where we're
actually going to want to perform the
update logic for making the velocity
apply to the bird we're going to defer
that to the bird class we're going to
assume that we have a method called
update in our bird class which you're
going to implement shortly and that's
actually all we need to do in our main
class it's sort of the beauty of having
classes that you can delegate all this
work to your main file though it's still
getting quite large it's 108 lines it's
not 2 300 400 you know thousands of
lines of code because we're able to
break out this code and sort of
encapsulate it elsewhere so I'm going to
remember to save it this time and then
I'm going to go into the bird lua file
in that directory which is the same with
comments because I loaded it from the
official repo the same bird code that we
wrote before I'm going to go ahead and
do a couple of things so the first thing
that I'm going to do is define a
constant so I mentioned gravity before
gravity is gonna be a constant value
just like it is in real life I'm gonna
define it to 20 there's just some
arbitrary value this is a value that I
decided felt right but you can tune this
however you want there's no right or
wrong way to do it the less the gravity
is the slower it will fall and the more
you'll feel like you're sort of in outer
space around the moon or whatnot
we're going to also go ahead and define
recall that we need some way to keep
track of how our position is or how our
bird is falling we want a velocity a Y
velocity this is going to update our
position each frame and it's going to
make it feel like we're falling so we're
going to set our initial velocity to
zero the bursar is going to be in the
middle it's not gonna be falling yet
what we won't want to do is apply this
velocity so remember in our main file we
had and up we assume that we had an
update function but we haven't actually
implemented it yet so we're gonna do
that right now
we're gonna say
for an update DT it's gonna we're gonna
pass it in the same DT that we use in
our main file and we're gonna go ahead
and just say our velocity is equal to
our current velocity plus gravity times
Delta time we're just gonna scale
gravity by Delta time so it'll move the
same amount and no matter whether we're
running at time 10 frames per second or
60 frames per second and then we're
going to go ahead we have a velocity but
it's not actually changing our Y value
the Y value is what ultimately moves us
on the screen so we need to apply that
the our new Delta Y to our Y so we're
gonna go ahead and just do that so if
that Y gets self that Y Plus self dot
Delta Y dy and so if I go back into bird
3 assuming I saved everything we should
just fall straight to the screen if we
do not terribly useful but notice it's
kinda it's slightly hard to tell maybe
but it does move faster and faster frame
by frame because that Delta Y is
increasing as well as our Y and that
Delta Y is getting applied to our y
frame by frame we'll do it one more time
just that's funny to look at all right
so we have basic gravity super super
basic computation just keep track of
some gravity constant Delta Y increase
that and apply that to your Y and that
gives you gravity but flappy bird can
jump so we need to define a way to defy
gravity so we're gonna do the in bird
for we're gonna call this the anti
gravity update and we're going to talk
about how we can actually get that going
so I found this diagram which I felt was
pretty apt and it also covers a few of
the other concepts we talking about
today but see here this gravity that's
the constant we've just defined before
the 20 or whatever and this gets applied
at whatever value you want it to be this
gets applied frame by frame to your Y
what we want is this this vector here
this jump velocity we want some value to
sort of counteract this gravity that
we've been accumulating so how do we
think we can go about doing this
we can set gravity to some perhaps
negative value a high value and that'll
have the effect of frame-by-frame if we
if we go from you know some positive
value which is taking us down on the y
axis and we go to a negative value it's
gonna start frame by frame it's gonna
say let's say we start at negative five
or we set its velocity to negative five
it's gonna set Y to negative it's going
to set it to plus negative five pixels
plus negative four point nine pixels
four point eight pixel it's gonna shoot
us up pretty fast
in a series of pixels but since we're
applying gravity frame by frame this
value that we set before twenty it's
gonna have the effect twenty times Delta
x so it gets effectively divided by
sixty it's going to counteract to this
again so we're gonna shoot up pretty
fast but gravity's gonna start taking
hold immediately after and we're gonna
start getting the effect of our bird
jumping and then falling down to the
ground a couple of other things that
this diagram shows which I thought were
pretty cool
this pipe gap or a pipe gap distance
here something that we'll be talking
about pretty shortly because this needs
to be defined so that we can offset our
pipes pipe separation that's another
thing we'll be talking about and also
pipe width which is just an intrinsic
value characteristic of the pipe sprite
we'll be using but I thought it was a
very apt NY you did a a nice little
article if you want to look at this
about exploring game space they
computationally determined what would
make a flappy bird level difficult or
not and rated flappy bird levels that
were dynamically generated based on some
sort of scale so if you're curious is in
the slides but I thought it was a cool
find as I was putting together this
lecture so what we need to do is then
simply add some negative value to
gravity negative sort of anti-gravity so
we're gonna go ahead and do that so in
bird for of
a little mini repo that I have here
we're gonna go ahead in Maine first one
thing that we want to do is because
another part of this is taking input
from the user being able to jump we want
to be able to detect whether they've
pressed space but if we want to detect
input for every single entity that we
ever like in again in an instance like
this it's not terribly important but
let's say we have like 20 or 30
different kinds of entities and they all
have their own input handling we don't
want to clobber Maine with that
necessarily so we can dedicate that
delegate that I should say to another
section of the code in this case we can
sort of put our Birds input handling
together with our bird class right and
sort of expand up upon the model of the
class or taking control of the code and
data for that a particular object in our
scene so what we're going to do is in
our love dot load I'm gonna go ahead and
do something here I'm gonna go ahead and
set I'm gonna go ahead and set love
keyboard keys pressed equals a table and
what I'm doing is just adding on to a
table that love defines called love
keyboard I'm adding my own value into it
called keys pressed and I'm assigning it
to an empty table so what we're gonna do
this is part of this is now part of what
love gives us as part of its SDK but
it's it's something that we've created
ourselves and you can do this because in
lua basically everything beyond basic
variables are just tables and you can
manipulate tables however you want in
this case love keyboard is a table I'm
just adding a new key called keys press
and I'm assigning it to an empty table
of my own we're gonna see how this is
actually used in just a moment so I'm
gonna go ahead in our
keep pressed function here this function
is called every time a user presses a
key in the game but I'm gonna use it
because this because it does that I can
go ahead and just do something like this
love dot keyboard keys pressed key gets
true and what that means is in this
table that we've just defined we've
created ourselves any time the user
presses any key because the love key
pressed gets called for you we can
safely rest assured that this is going
to get populated no matter what key
they've pressed because it's just
something that love 2d takes care of you
but it's not getting stored until now
now we're actually going to keep track
of it in our own table for reasons that
will become apparent very shortly the
next part of this code is defining a
custom function so the impetus for this
is love defines a couple of functions it
defines a function called love keyboard
dot is down which takes in some key
value and you can use this to test for
continuous input which we did in the
last the last lecture we're saying hey
if up is down right now or down is down
then we need to update our Y velocity
accordingly but it doesn't have a
mechanism like this for let's say if we
want in some file other than main to
check for F of key but just press one
time it has this function loved key
pressed which takes a key and that will
trigger it but we can't access this
outside of this function because if we
define this function in bird Lua it's
gonna overwrite this implementation and
we don't necessarily want to have to
worry about other files overriding these
functions because who knows if you're on
a team especially who knows who's
overwritten love dot key pressed and
what module and what order does it get
loaded in and what functions actually
valid we're gonna take care of this
problem by giving ourselves the ability
to test for whether a keys been pressed
on the last frame by implementing a
function that we are also adding to the
keyboard namespace the keyboard table
ourselves called
was pressed
it's gonna take a key and all it's going
to do is check that table that we
created before it's gonna say if love
keyboard keys pressed key then return
true else return false and you could
actually just return love keyboard keys
pressed key and it'll be the exact same
thing and so what this has the effect of
doing is saying okay because on the
update which we're about to see actually
I should probably do that before so
that's all it gets tied together love
dot at the end of love update we're
gonna do one last thing and that's reset
that table because we want to just check
frame by frame so we have we have a
table a global table that we've created
to check for whether keys pressed we
have a callback function that love to
digas us that allows us to do that so
every time a key gets pressed we're
going to just add that key to that table
and set it to true now we can just
simply query that table anytime we want
to with this function that we've created
called love keyboard was pressed key
which means on the last frame was that
key pressed basically return whether
it's true or false now the only problem
is we're not flushing it we're not ever
setting that to false that is the effect
of if we just press all the keys in our
keyboard those will always be false
always be true until we reinitialize the
table to some empty value which is what
we do here on the update which takes
place after all inputs been detected
we're going to just set that table to an
empty table again and on the next frame
it's going to whatever keys we pressed
those will get set to true and then we
can just query that table here as needed
and any update henceforth so does
anybody anybody have any questions as to
how this is operating
and so the ultimate driving factor for
us as to why we want to do this we want
to put in the work to sort of keep track
of this global input table is so that we
can actually query input single key
input based on our based in other files
outside of main Lua because currently
all we can do to check for single key
presses is look in main dot Lua but
that's not what we want to do we're
gonna go ahead and go to our bird Aloha
and in our update function this is where
we actually get to use our efforts and
say if love keyboard that was pressed
space which is the key that we want to
actually allow us to jump go ahead and
set self dy to where should we send self
dot dy to when we press spacebar should
be a positive or a negative value and
negative about you will say it's a
negative five and we should probably
define this as an antigravity constant
up here but just for the sake of speed
we'll say self dot dy gets negative five
and so and I did say that right I did
say that I'm going to go ahead and go
into bird for go ahead and run this
example and look at that
we're jumping but we can still fall to
the ground and we don't have any real
gameplay but we've come a long ways now
we've taken input single key input that
we otherwise didn't have the ability to
do in love 2d we've made it possible by
just keeping track of our global input
State and flushing it every update so
does anybody have any questions as to
how that works ok so the other big major
visual component of flappy bird are
these pipes that we see here on the
screen we have two pipes there but the
screen is filled with infinite pipes so
does anybody have any instinct as to how
we can implement this well we'll see
before long but suffice to say we'll
need a new sprite we'll need some sort
of way of keeping track of when to spawn
them because they sort of spawn you know
after a period of time and that'll be
sort of our gap and then what happened
will happen if we just let it spawn
forever and ever we do because if we
don't do that after a certain period of
time we're allocating memory for each of
these pipes not a ton of memory just you
know essentially an X Y width and a
height but because they all referenced
the same there will reference the same
sprite image but given enough time
eventually you're going to allocate a
certain number of bytes that will exceed
your computer's memory or the amount of
allocated memory and you'll either hang
infinitely or crash and so we want to
destroy them as they go as well so we're
gonna go ahead and look at sort of the
final live coded example just because
from here on out it's gonna be a little
bit much I'm gonna go ahead and go to
main dot Lua first
so just give my notes in order the first
thing we want to do oh I'm actually in
the wrong repo - I apologize I was in
the district we go I want to be in the
scratch repo so I'm gonna go ahead go
into Maine I'm gonna require pipe now we
don't have a pipe yet but this is a
perfect example of how we can sort of
keep abstracting our game we have a bird
class but we should also probably have a
pipe class because a pipe is a distinct
type of entity in our game world we can
sort of model it as a unit we can give
it functions we can give it data and
think about it in terms of it being a
pipe not being a set of XY with height
you know etc whatever whatever data you
want to ascribe to it we can abstract
that out and think in more abstract
terms which will allow us to scale a
little bit better so we're going to go
ahead and assume that we have a pipe
class I'm gonna go ahead go ahead and
add it to our folder here right now so
do a new file pipe doll Lua and I'm
gonna go ahead reference my notes here
for just a second
go ahead and so the pipe class is
actually quite simple just like the bird
class was initially we don't need to
keep track of a lot of data but we do
want to keep track of a few things so
the bird would there's only ever gonna
be one bird out at once but with a pipes
we're gonna be spawning them over and
over again and so if we allocate them
out for each pipe that we instantiate if
we allocate a new image this is probably
not super efficient right we're using
the same exact data we have a bunch of
pipes we only really need one sprite so
outside of the init function so just
below where we're declaring that pipe is
a class we're gonna go ahead and create
a local variable that is still scoped to
this file but there's only ever going to
be one copy of this object we're going
to go ahead and call it say that we have
pipe dot PNG in this folder and this is
sort of separated out from the functions
that we're going to be defining in here
but this has the effect of sort of
creating a semi global graphics object
even though it's contained within this
this class file it's not accessible
outside of this class file because we
don't need it to be but it's also not
being instantiated every single time
because recall if we look at bird lua
here we're just setting it as self dot
image gets love dot graphics new image
bird dot PNG this will have the effect
of allocating a new image every time we
create a bird object but we only ever
create one bird object so it's not
really an important design consideration
for us to say maybe we should create a
you know global semi global image up
here it's not it's not important in this
in this context probably good style to
do so anyway for larger projects but
just a consideration for here not really
something we need to worry about but yes
definitely try to take an asset and
reference it as reference it rather than
allocate it as many times as possible
we want our pipes to scroll so we need
some sort of value just like we did with
the backgrounds we need some value that
keeps track of whether these pipes are
scrolling and it can be a constant value
we're gonna directly call it negative 60
this time and not sort of negate it when
we add it to our position later on so
pipe scroll negative 60 we can just add
it directly to our X or to our well yeah
in this case just to our X and that'll
have the times Delta time of course and
that'll have the effect of shifting it
left because it's a negative number will
define the init function here so pipe in
it within the init function bring into a
couple of things so it's X where should
the X be what should the X be set to
let's say if we want the pipe to spawn
be on the right edge of the screen yep
virtual width and you could you could
also say virtual width plus some number
if you wanted to because it's set to 0 0
it's going to have a if you won't see it
on the frame that it gets instantiated
but yes virtual width or virtual width
plus some constant value or some value
that you've allocated ahead of time
we'll just set it to virtual width so as
soon as the pipe gets initialized
it'll be invisible but it's gonna be
right on the right edge of the screen
what about our Y value first of all
let's take a look at what the image
looks like so we can see it's gonna be
in our don't think I have the actual
image in that directory so I'm going to
come here when I grab the pipe this is
what the pipe looks like let's see if I
can expand it a little bit
so it's kind of tall where should we
probably place it if we wanted to look
sort of similar to flappy bird probably
towards like the lower end of the screen
we can get fancy with it too and we can
even maybe make it randomized just like
flappy bird so we'll go ahead and do
that I'm gonna go ahead and copy this
and put it into our scratch folder here
back in the init function I'm going to
go ahead and set self dot why - because
we want to talk about procedural
generation this would be sort of our
first foray into how we randomized this
we'll be using the function that we used
last week and this is a ubiquitous
function you'll see this everywhere and
any framework or game engine you use
math dot random we want it to be the
lower half of the screen so let's say
virtual height divided by four is the
upper bound and maybe virtual height
minus ten as the upper bound so that'll
have the effect of setting it to roughly
a quarter of the screen or sorry virtual
height divided by four is towards the
top end of the screen and then virtual
height minus ten is the lower end of the
screen so it's actually going to cover
anywhere from the first quarter below
that down to about ten pixels from the
bottom I do it in Maine so in this file
I'm not sure if I did it for this
demonstration it has definitely set in
the repo the
I don't think I said it in this example
but yes you would set the random seat
here if you wanted to run every time oh
sorry and the question was do we should
we set the random seed in the bird file
or should we set it in mein Lua
typically you want to set it at the top
level of your application so we're going
to set it in we're going to go ahead and
set it in the in main and the function
itself is here and I think it's starting
in bird six onwards so it'll be should I
not set it
I may not have set the random seed until
later in the repo let's check bird
twelve so yes math dot random seed and
then seed by OS dot time as we use last
week in class I won't I'll set it here
probably will only run it once but it'll
it'll have the effect now we can run it
several times just to see the difference
in the pipes let's go back to our pipe
da lua here and we have the X we have
the Y so those are set accordingly we
also want to set the width
does anybody recall what the function is
to get a the width of a graphics object
and the syntax for that
so we have our image up here pipe image
love that graphics that new image piped
up PNG exactly so we're gonna go ahead
and set this to pipe image : get width
and that will become our new and that'll
allow us to store with for when we we
will use it later and then we need a few
other functions so the pipe will spawn
but it won't move because we have them
applied any sort of scrolling to it we
have the scrolling variable up on line 5
but we need to actually apply it to our
pipe so we're gonna go ahead and create
an update function and then in that
update function very similar to what
we've seen before already pipe scroll
times Delta time and then lastly we want
to render our pipe so we're going to go
ahead and call a function that we've
seen already today loved our graphics
draw we're gonna use the pipe image up
above and then we're gonna go ahead and
use self dot X and self dot Y and that's
all we need for our pipe and let me make
sure that that's all we really need so
in main download we got to go back to
main da lua to because we actually have
to start spawning pipes so let's go
ahead and go to pull up my code here one
more time
in Maine so online 59 I'm sorry you
won't see it you'll see it line 59 in
the actual district code but for me it's
going to be different slightly different
we're going to go ahead and create a new
table to keep track of all the pipes
that we want to spawn because we need a
way to store them in memory we can't
just set you know one variable to
basically a dynamic almost like a
dynamic array in this case but we're
gonna or a linked list rather we're
going to use this table just to hold
them we're not going to give them keys
we're just going to insert them like we
would do with just a linked list like in
Python for example we're going to go
ahead and what do we need to do if we
want to sort of have them spawn after a
certain period of time probably want to
like have some sort of timer we want to
like keep track of how much time has
passed and maybe have some sort of
amount of time that's our like trigger
to spawn up a pipe let's say maybe like
two seconds so if we set a timer to zero
it's gonna start just at zero but we can
add to this frame by frame we can just
increase this timer by Delta time
whatever that is frame by frame it'll be
about a sixtieth of a second so after
sixty frames have passed we'll get one
second after 120 frames to pass we'll
have two seconds at that point we can
then decide okay now it's time to spawn
a new pipe let's go ahead and do that so
I'm gonna go ahead and in our update
function
we want to handle the actual increasing
of this timer so it's as simple as make
sure that I called it spawn timer I hope
I just called it timer let's go it's on
timer be a little more specific about we
want here so our spawn timer and then
we're going to go ahead in our update
and set spawn time or equal to spawn
timer plus Delta time and then what we
need to do is then check is our spawn
timer greater than because it keeps
track of time in seconds Delta time will
give you a fractional amount in second
so we at point zero one three or
something like that we want to keep
track of whether spawn timers gone past
two right so if spawn timer is greater
than two we want to add a new pipe does
anybody remember the function for how to
add to a table in lua so it's table dot
insert so table dot insert will take in
a table so in this case we want the
pypes table that we allocated before and
then we're gonna put in a new pipe
object right i call this is how you
instantiate an object or call
parenthesis that will have the effect of
now our pipes table is going to every
time we call this it's going to get a
new index so it's going to start at one
lua
tables are indexed at one first time it
happens index one is going to be equal
to a new pipe object which is going to
start it's X Y at the edge of the screen
then index two will be the exact same
thing a new pipe that's at the edge of
the screen and so on and so forth every
time we call table that insert
once our spine timer has exceeded two if
we want this to not spawn pipe every
frame hereafter which would quickly clog
up our our world we want to reset our
spawn timer 0 so this will have the
effect of now it's going to wait another
2 seconds and then this condition will
be true again and then we can add a new
pipe to the scene let's go ahead and
look at a we're going to need to add a
new set of logic here actually I'm going
to put all of this above the bird update
and then below that I'm going to go
ahead and do I'm not sure if we've
covered this already don't think we have
but if we want to iterate over a table
there's a function that Lua gives you
called pairs it will give you all the
key value pairs of a table that you can
then use while you're iterating over it
similar to enumerate and Python if
familiar except this will actually give
you the keys rather than just the
indices so we can do for K pipe in pairs
of pipes do some body of code and then
we have access to the key and the pipe
within this we can just iterate over it
and use it so first thing we want to do
is we want to update our pipe so for
each pipe update it give it the Delta
time of the current frame and then what
was the other important feature so this
will have the effect of scrolling it now
it's going to get its X shifted but what
was the other important thing we need to
do with every pipe in our scene
yes that is exactly true so what we're
gonna do is if pipe X is less than so if
we did less than zero what do we think
would happen it would have it would we
would see it instantly disappear because
it's there there based on the top left
coordinate so what we need to do is keep
track of the its width so what we'll do
is we'll just say if pipe X is less than
negative pipe width which will allow the
pipe to go all the way past the edge of
the screen we'll call a function called
table remove which takes a table in this
case pipes and then it takes a key and
the key we have access to up above on
line 124 we can just say K and that'll
have the effect of removing that pipe
from the scene and then as soon as
that's done we're good to go the last
thing that we need to do is currently
we're not actually drawing the pipes to
the screen so down below in our render
function we're gonna go ahead and up
above before we do the ground because if
we do it normally if we do it after we
we render the ground it's gonna the
pipes are gonna look like they're just
kind of like layered on top of the
ground we want it to look as if they're
sticking out from the ground so we want
to do is have a correct render layer a
render draw order to the screen which
all the background we draw the pipes
then we draw the ground and this will
have the effect of looking as if the
pipes are sticking out of the ground so
what we'll do is we'll do the exact same
thing we just did up above by saying for
K comma pipe in pairs of pipes do
pipe and then the render function that
we defined in pipe and those have the
effect of iterating through all the
pipes and our seen every draw call and
drawing them before it draws the ground
and before it draws the bird and that
should be all that we need to illustrate
this example make sure everything is
saved I'm going to go ahead and go into
bird 5 if I did everything correctly
this should after a certain period of
time drop hypes to the screen that are
scrolling and they're randomized their
y-values getting set to some value
between the top quarter of the screen so
about starting wrap out right we're
flappy bird is right now down to about
10 pixels above the width of the screen
which actually that looks like 10 pixels
above so that's a slight bug it should
probably be something along the lines of
30 or 40 we won't encounter that in the
final distro because they're not set to
spawn that low but you can see how this
is sort of the beginning of our
procedural level generation system and
we have most all the components of our
scene now we get normally in flappy bird
we have two pipes we have a pipe that's
above and then a pipe that's below and
this sort of in pairs and the next
example we're actually going to start
illustrating this we're gonna have pairs
of pipes that are joined together which
scroll together that once you fly
through them you score a point but for
now we sort of have all the pieces that
we need in order to get you know it sort
of have the basic visual sense of the
game completed we're gonna take a like a
five-minute break now and then once we
come back we'll actually dive into how
we can get pairs of pipes into our scene
and start getting into scoring and some
other fun things like music so alright
welcome back so the next part
so before we establish the bird the
background the pipes we have all the
visual aspects of our game sort of ready
to go the next important piece of the
puzzle to really solve is how can we
start scoring our game and also how can
we get the pipes matching the way that
they are implemented in the actual game
which recall they're normally in pairs
as illustrated here and we also see on
the right
as we've covered already so far we have
the spawn zone for our pipes and on the
Left we have what I've labeled the dead
zone where pipes are sort of d
instantiated once they've gotten past
the negative width of themselves but
pipes come in pairs they get shifted and
the once the bird flies between these
gaps is ultimately when they've scored a
point and so we need a way to pair pipes
together and sort of define this sort of
logic for how can we tell whether the
bird has gone past the the gap and
whether or not the pipes have been d
instantiate it so we're gonna go ahead
and I'm gonna probably stop live coding
for the rest of the demonstrations
because they're gonna be a little bit
more complex but I believe my code
editor is over here I'm gonna go ahead
and open up oh this is my other editor
okay so in the base repo now we're gonna
go ahead and look at the full example so
in bird six which is the pair pipe pair
update our cat their current subfolder
that we're looking at we're gonna start
in main so on line 33 in main we can see
that we're requiring pipe pair which is
a new class we're defining we're taking
the pipe that we had before and we're
sort of creating a new composite class
we're gonna take a class that sort of
encapsulates two pipes together a pair
of pipes and we're going to use this to
think about our problem more abstractly
than we already are and this sort of
layering of abstractions is a very
important concept in computer science
generally speaking but especially in
games where you might have objects that
are composites of objects that are
composites of objects and these abstract
hierarchies are sort of what keeps
programmers sane when dealing with such
you know large levels of when you have
thousands of lines of code sort of the
only way you can really make sense of it
so on line 65 if we look now instead of
a table that's called pipes where we've
been renamed it two pipe pairs we're no
longer gonna store individual pipes in
our scene we're gonna sort of take these
pipe pairs that we're gonna create and
store them in our table as well as whole
as like individual units
on line 71 we need a variable to keep
track of the we're calling it last why
the purpose of this variable is so that
we can keep track of where the last set
of pipes are spawn their gap right
because we if we made our gaps
completely random it'll have the sort of
effect of not looking continuous for one
and also potentially being impossible to
beat we want some sort of smooth contour
to our gaps so that we can fly through
them reasonably and that it looks as if
it was almost pre-made and smooth so
we're gonna keep track of a variable
called last y we're gonna start it off
at negative pipe height so up past the
top of the screen plus some sort of
value between between 1 and 80 and 20 so
it's gonna be it's gonna be roughly
towards the top of the screen and this
is important because last Y is going to
be where we're gonna end up flipping our
sprite and I'll flip on the y-axis has
the result of the sprite sort of looking
as if it's gone it's holed height above
where it's actual Y is and we'll see in
more detail shortly why this ends up
working the way it does we're gonna go
down to line 132 and in our sort of
condition if our spawn timer is greater
than 2 what we're gonna do is this is
where we spawn our pipes before but now
responding pairs of pipes so we're gonna
set a local variable Y it's gonna be
this is the the clamp operation that we
talked about sort of last week using
mathematics and mathematics ort of like
apply some sort of operation in this
case we're gonna add a random value
between negative 20 and 22 whatever our
last y-value was which is going to shift
the gap effectively by negative 20 or 20
pixels we're gonna clamp it between
negative pi pipe plus 10 so about 10
pixels from the top of the screen and
then
we're gonna set the upper bound to
virtual height - 90 - pi PI and this -
pipe height is only because we're doing
a flip operation on our y-axis for our
sprite I'll go into it in a little bit
more detail sort of try to make it clear
as to why we're doing it and maybe I'll
take out some codes to illustrate what
it looks like without that operation
applied but basically it has the effect
of 90 pixels from the bottom is where
the pipe could the the gap could spawn
so basically the pipe at the very bottom
we recall that this gap is where the
this value is where the the gap itself
begins not necessarily where the pipe
starts it'll be between negative pi PI
plus 10 between negative basically
effectively between 10 pixels from the
top of the screen between negative
and/or between 90 pixels from the bottom
of the screen and then we're going to
apply a random permutation of this value
we're gonna add some value between
negative 20 and 20 and that will sort of
give us a contour and it'll be a sort of
a randomized contour line 136 we have
pipe pairs table insert into that
instead of pipes and we're just adding a
new pipe pair and we're setting it to
that the value of y and then this the
pipe pair takes in a Y value and that'll
be where the start of the gap is and
what but this will have the effect of
doing is it's going to flip a sprite
above the gap so that we have a pipe
right above where the gap starts and
then it's going to draw another pipe
unflexible oh that and that will be how
it sort of puts the two together line
144 is a loop that just updates our
pairs instead of our pipes so we've just
all we've done here is just renamed it
from pipe to pair and we've instead of
pipe as if pipes were using pipe pairs
we're doing the same exact thing here
one on line 153 that we've done for K
pair in pairs of pipe pairs and then
line 150 sorry line 175
is where we are or sorry 170 is where we
are rendering each pair instead of each
pipe and so if we open up pipe pair here
we can take a look at this class from
scratch so it's a new class we're gonna
set our gap height to 90 pixels and so
this is just some arbitrary value that I
felt was like a pretty fair value in
terms of size but you could tune this to
whatever you want you could set this to
what you want to be really cruel you
could set something like 50 or if you
wanted to be really generous to the
player you could set it to something
like 150 and make it fairly easy for
them to get through or as part of the
assignment you could randomize it so
that the so that varies you know pair by
pair and you get more of an organic
looking obstacle-course
still shifted by a negative 22 20 pixels
but now your gap varies and you can also
randomize the shift amount if you wanted
to as well let's say you wanted maybe
the maybe you want the gaps to be up to
40 pixels difference instead of 20
pixels difference on negative and
positive value you could easily do that
as well
on line 18 we're just setting our X to
just like we did before
virtual width plus 32 so we're setting
it to the actually before we just set it
to virtual width now we're setting it to
virtual width plus 32 both are pretty
much equal this will just give it a
little bit of a delay before it ends up
going onto the screen but you could
effectively just do this virtual width
the on the next line 24 this is where we
sort of bundled together the pipes that
we're going to end up actually rendering
and updating to the screen instead of
having just one pipe a pipe Paris two
pipes we can easily put this together in
a table so we'll just create self dot
pipes we'll set it to a table that has
two keys upper and lower and the upper
pipe is just a pipe and notice one thing
is different about pipe now before it
took no arguments it was just a regular
pipe pipes had their own logic they say
set their own X&Y they didn't need any
sort of you know parameterization beyond
that it was all taken care of for them
randomly
now they take a string so this top
string means that this would be a top
pipe so that means that if this pipe is
a top pipe there's probably going to be
logic in pipe that now checks to see
whether it's top or bottom if it's top
then we need to render it upside down we
need to flip it along the y-axis and
then we're gonna set it to self dot Y
and recall that we set self dot y we
passed in self dot Y and main actually
I'm not sure if I touched on that let's
go back to main here so if we go to
figure out where I actually instantiate
how the pipes here on line 136 after
we've calculated where we want the gap
to be for this pipe pair we're gonna go
ahead and insert into pipe pairs a pipe
pair at why why was the calculation
between basically took the last Y value
the last gap that we instantiated and
then shifted it by some negative 20 to
20 pixels randomly and made sure it
didn't go above or beyond above or below
the edges of the screen the back end
pipe pair we're gonna go ahead and look
at line 30 or sorry actually will let's
take a look a little bit more closely
here at line 26 so upper gets top and
self dot Y that's where the gap is and
that's the sprites going to be flipped
upon that value the lower value is going
to be a shift of that so the lower
sprite needs to spawn below the top pipe
by the gap amount so that the two are
sort of you know top to bottom but there
needs to be that space between the two
of them so we need to take that pipe
shift it down and then draw the next
pipe so we're going to take self dot y
plus pipe height plus gap height
and that'll have the effect a member gap
height was 90 pixels the pipe height is
a result of sort of flipping the the why
act the y-axis is having to shifted down
the actual position so if we go back to
line 30 so this is a this is an
interesting sort of illustration of what
happens when you edit a table while
you're iterating over a table and I'll
show you this in detail shortly but
basically on line 30 we're setting a
flag called remove to false and what
this is going to do is before we were
just destroying the objects whenever it
got past the edge of the screen we just
destroyed it but if we're iterating over
a table of values let's say a table of
pipe pairs when you do a removal in most
programming languages been in Lua when
you do a removal of a table of a table
value and it's non indexed or it's non
keyed which means that it's indexed by
you know numerical indices this will
shift every other value down and so when
you're iterating it and you you shift
everything down the value you are
currently manipulating let's say it's
equal to one if you remove that value
you shift everything beyond it down by
one but then you're going to increment
up to two and you're skipping over what
was previously just two and is now one
so you effectively skipping over one of
your entries and that has buggy behavior
and a lot of scenarios in this case it
causes the graphics to sort of glitch a
little bit because it doesn't apply a
pixel shift on one frame and so as picks
as whenever a pipe gets removed and I
can actually show this visually the
first pipe left after that table of that
pipe gets removed ends up moving a
little bit to the right and so you get
weird pipes shifting to the left of the
bird on each frame so whenever you edit
a table in place make sure not to delete
while you're iterating over it it's
going to cause buggy behavior
and like I said I'll show you that all
I'll illustrate this for you very
shortly on line 36 we are performing the
update logic now a pipe pair has two
pipes each with their own render
components and their own positions we
were using the code that we wrote before
for pipe and we're going to try to
expand upon it a little bit so we want
to defer it we still want to defer a lot
of that code to the pipe class and we
want to update the pipes based on
whether they we want to still keep track
of their own X in their render functions
and so we're going to see if basically
if our pipe pair X is greater than
negative pipe width which is the same
exact logic that we're using before set
our own X to the that minus pipe speed
times Delta time which is the same
operation we were doing before but we
are also editing the X of our self pipes
lower and upper and this will allow us
to on line 46 render the pipes just as
we were doing before because they're
getting their X values updated just as
they were before so are effectively
deferring the render phase to our pipes
and not really needing to add any
additional logic for that in our code if
we've made changes to pipe that Lua as
well so I'm going to go ahead and open
up pipe here oops
and we've set the height and width of it
as constants here so pipehype gets 288
and that happens to be about the size of
the screen pipe width gets 70 on 31
we're sitting self that orientation gets
orientation notice our init function
which was previously just empty it took
no parameters now takes an orientation
and it takes a while you the orientation
is going to be going to allow us to say
to ask basically is our code a top pipe
or a bottom pipe and if it's a top pipe
we need to flip it draw it and shift it
if it's a bottom pipe we're just gonna
draw normal and not perform any sort of
fancy you know sprite flipping or
anything like that down here on the
render function is where this actually
happens so on line 39 we're drawing the
pipe image as usual at X but at Y
because when you flip a sprite it ends
up completely flipping the white but it
basically performs a mirror on it but it
not at 0-0
it basically shifts it up by pipe height
amount we need to keep track of that and
draw it at self that y plus pipe height
because if we draw it at just self dot Y
because it's going to be mirrored and
it's gonna get shifted by pipe height
amount it's gonna be B on the top edge
of the screen we need to account for
that account for the fact that we're
flipping it on the y axis and bring it
down the code where we the question is
where's the code where we flip it so
that's actually here on this line on
this condition we're saying if self the
orientation is equal to top then we want
to so the parameters here I'll comment
this just for clarification it does and
I'll show you here so this is zero we've
added a few new parameters to our love
dog graphics draw function zero is
rotation we're not going to rotate it at
all this is the scale on the x axis so X
scale and this is the scale on the y
axis so if we apply a scale operation of
1 it's the same thing as applying no ski
like doing no scale at all it's gonna
draw it on the x-axis it's just gonna
draw it normally but if it's top if
we're if this pipe has been set to an
orientation of top
we need to we're going to set the scale
to negative one when you set a sprite
its scale factor to negative one it
flips it along that axis effectively and
so that's how you get mirroring in most
engines that allow you to sort of apply
scale operations to 2d textures or 2d
sprites a negative operation on an axis
will mirror it on that axis and so
that's what we're doing here so we're
mirroring it if it's a top pipe and
we're also shifting its draw location as
well because when we mirror it it's
going to at 0 0 it's going to do the
same again a basically draw the same
exact thing but mirrored on the y-axis
so it's going to need it's gonna if we
want to draw it at a given location
flipped like still draw it at 0 0 but
have it be flipped we need to account
for that flip and shift it downwards if
that makes sense
so that's essentially all that's
involved there and I think that's pretty
much all the code so we have our pipes
now that are being when its flipped if
it's a top pipe it's gonna get drawn
shifted it's going to have its other
pipe shifted down by that amount and set
to negative or set and increased its
y-axis is gonna be increased by the gap
height so that it gets drawn you know 90
pixels however many pixels you want to
set below that pipe so we're gonna go in
to demonstrate this go up to
50 bird the actual repo now and the
actual district code I'm going to go
into bird six I'm gonna run it whoops
and now we have pipes that are actually
rendering but we're missing a couple of
important things foremost among them
being then now we don't have we don't
have collision detection yet so we can
just fly through this course you know
infinitely but notice that they're being
shifted by you know random value between
negative 20 and 20 pixels it looks more
or less like it's being generated with
some sort of goal in mind it's it's not
you know haphazard not all over the
place but you can easily find ways to
tweak this such that you know maybe the
gap height is some value between you
know 60 and 120 and so you have easy and
difficult pipes or maybe you have I
think I'm so far below the screen that I
can't even get back up anymore but oh
okay I just that's physics error and
when you when your value gets to a
certain point I think that's actually
what's doing is actually overflowing the
value and setting it to a a negative or
under flowing it and setting it to a
negative value and then incrementing it
because it's gotten so large but the but
you could easily modulate parameters
such as the width between the pipes as
we saw in the diagram before or they or
the height or even the speed at which
they move and find ways you know tune it
to make game play that actually works
for whatever goal you have in mind
making it easier or more difficult and
that's actually a topic that they talked
about in that article that I linked to
before where they generated levels
programmatically and then tested them
programmatically to determine what makes
a level in flappy bird difficult or easy
and so basically that's
those are the parameters you need to
sort of weigh as you're thinking of
procedural generation and procedural
generation ultimately is just taking
values that you construct your scene
with and just finding ways to just
manipulate them randomly math dot random
some value and that's how you make
random levels in a nutshell making good
random levels is another question but he
did he did that was a big controversy
around this game back in 2013 but I
didn't know if I read too much into that
but I was doing a little bit of a little
bit of research and was reading about
some of that stuff but I mean I got to
give him props for you know banking on
that but yeah that's you know we have
pipe pairs that's arguably the most
complex part of the program because
going forward now as we get into
collision and some more concepts
collision is actually something that we
touched on last week and it's all
basically the same stuff so if we go
into birds 7 the next iteration of our
application I'm going to go ahead and
open up main.lua and then we're gonna go
to line 74 and in order to test
collision we got we don't have scoring
in place yet but we need some way to
just set to determine oh we collided
with the pipe we need some sort of
feedback so what we're gonna do is I've
just decided we should just pause the
game so once we once we collide with the
pipe let's just pause instantly so you
know immediately o-week lie with a pipe
so I'm gonna set some variable called
scrolling at the top of the program in
main to true it's gonna we're scrolling
we're gonna start scrolling but when I
don't want to scroll anymore when I want
to pause the game this should get set to
false so on line 120 if scrolling then
do all of this update logic that we did
before and then at the very end of that
we're resetting our input table so we
can still take input but no updates will
take place if scrolling is set to false
all of this stuff is within
if excuse me if scrolling then so very
simple just encapsulate it all within
some variable that we can turn on and
off and then on 1:52 within that chunk
of code that is being sort of contained
within that if condition we're just
doing a very simple iteration for each
pipe this should be 4l pair in pairs of
oh no sorry for every pipe in the pairs
of it's an S it's nested for loop in
this case so basically within the the
loop that looks over every single pair
to update it we're doing another loop
that's looping through with the pipes in
that pair so it's only a loop of two
iterations with the upper and the lower
pipe we could just also say if bird
collides with upper basically if peridot
upper peridot lower or peridot pipe
setup or peridot pipes down lower but
this is a little cleaner it's more
scalable we can add more pipes if we
want to even though that wouldn't happen
but for every pipe in peridot pipes we
have a function here that we haven't
defined yet called bird collides so if
bird collides pipe so it takes in a pipe
so this is going to return a true or
false value we know that that's going to
false so we collide what's going set to
false update law just gonna get shut off
completely so we're gonna have the
effect of pause in the game we're going
to go into bird lua right now we're
gonna actually see how we implement this
and it's gonna look very familiar to
what we did last week
so in bird lua this function here from
29 down to 45 it's just an AABB
collision detection test that we did
last week we're just checking to make
sure any edges are you know with right
edge make sure that is to the left of
the right edge of the second box bottom
edge of box one should be our bottom
edge of box one should be above bottom
edge of our top edge of box two if all
of these things hold true then return
true else return false which means we
have a collision and notice that I've
shifted everything here by a couple of
constant values does anybody have any
instinct as to why I'm saying self dot X
- instead of just self-taught X or
self-taught with - for why we're
checking for that offset for the bird in
this case when it is compared with the
pipe it's not quite half it's a few
pixels smaller do we know why we want to
do this why we want to like we're
basically shrinking the box why would we
want to shrink the box so not quite so
there isn't an actual gap between the
drawing it's more of a question of how
much do we want to frustrate how much we
want to frustrate our users right if if
we're pixel perfect colliding with the
pipes you know there's there's no
give-and-take it's like you you collide
and even if you it might even look as if
you're not even colliding with the pipe
and you're still getting a collision
your users are thinking well that's not
fair that's really harsh we're shrinking
our box so that you know even if they're
just like a pixel off they'll still get
a little bit of leeway and it'll be a
little bit less strict in terms of the
collision and this is a very common
thing in games when you have characters
whose sprites may not necessarily fill
the entire box that you've allocated for
them even though you're doing box
collision just give your users a couple
pixels deep however however many you
want and they can overlap with whatever
they're colliding with just a tiny bit
before it actually triggers a true on
the collision and it makes your game
feel more forgiving and then also more
fun as a result of that so that's why we
have where instead of testing directly
on X 0 of that box we're testing X plus
2 and then self dot width minus 4
because when we shift we'll add with - a
plus 2 value we need minus 4 so that we
get to off the right edge and same thing
goes for the height and the y value and
so this just performs a abb collision
detection expects a pipe which means
that we need to ensure that the pipe has
an x and a y a width and a height which
it does actually just a constant here
we're just checking pipe with and pipe
height we probably shouldn't do that it
should be pipe dot with pipe dot height
in that case because then this couldn't
necessarily just be a pipe it could be
anything in our scene that has
a XY a width and a height it could be a
general-purpose collision and actually
something you can also do if you wanted
to is just write a function called
collides that takes into two things that
you know have bounding boxes and will
allow you to perform collision detection
on anything in your scene and eat
between any two entities that would be a
more scalable way of guess of dealing
with it rather than necessarily having
it specifically defined as birds and
pipes being a colliders but in this case
this is the only thing we're really
colliding with except from the ground
but when you collide with the ground all
you need to do is just check to see
whether your Y position plus your height
has gone below the edge of the screen so
any questions as to how that so a
question was why did we add two and
subtract four instead of just subtract
two because when you add a because we're
doing self dot X plus two
basically we're shifting the whole box
essentially here in this part so self
dot X plus two brings the beginning of
the box that word that we're colliding
with to pixels to the right but if we
just do two pixels minus 2 then we're
there boxes X right edge is still the
right edge of the box we want it to be
shifted inwards by two by two pixels
because we've shifted at the start of
our box the x position two pixels over
we need to shift it four pixels inwards
because that will give us the that'll
have the effect of our box having being
two pixels into the right edge summing
sense
okay so I think that's everything for
birds seven we're gonna go ahead and run
bird seven now and recall if we hit a
pipe we should instantly pause so
bouncing bouncing bouncing I'm going to
go through one pair of pipes here and
then I hit this one purpose
oh we paused and notice that we have a
little bit of leeway we got a couple
pixels there just to give us you know in
case we accidentally and also it takes
into consideration you could move
because of your velocity a couple pixels
beyond the necessarily the strict hard
edge of what you're colliding with based
on how many you know how many frames
have passed and what your delta well
you're basically essentially what your
velocity is and what your position is in
this case I think it looks like we're
actually like three or four pixels above
the edge because our velocity was so
high because we jumped but as soon as it
detected the collision as soon as we
were on that frame where our position
was such that we did trigger true for
our collision detection it paused the
game looping was set to false we no
longer ran any update logic and this is
our basic way of getting feedback about
that however it's not particularly
compelling gameplay wise and so we want
to get into scoring before we get into
scoring though and also associated with
that different states of our game so if
we get into scoring clearly we want to
have a screen that tells us when we lost
and how what our score was we should
also probably have a title screen
because we're just jumping right into
the gameplay we want it's a screen that
lets us play through the game and as
we'll see in a little bit a screen that
also gives us some time to once we start
the game to sort of count down sort of
say oh three two one go rather than just
oak go and oh I don't know what I'm
doing I'm bewildered so this is sort of
a diagram that sort of models the state
flow that we're going to be using in our
program here our game we're gonna assume
that we start on some sort of title
screen States so going left to right a
title screen state will transition to
the countdown state and then we can
define however we want those transitions
to be in this case let's just say we
press Enter title screen see it goes
countdown state once countdown state has
once the transition has triggered for
that we should go to the play state and
then once the transition triggers for
play state we're gonna go down to the
score state and then score state should
go back into countdown state and this
models our entire applications flow you
know sort of top to bottom left to right
chronologically so let's go ahead and
take a look at some code is how we're
gonna accomplish this last week I
alluded to taking us and actually
earlier in lecture us going from sort of
this string based approach to keeping
track of our state with if conditions to
a class based approach and that's where
we're going to illustrate today so I'm
going to go ahead and open up bird ate
and in bird ate I'm going to go ahead
and start with Maine
so in Maine on line 36 we're requiring a
new class called state machine and a few
other classes that we're defining called
base state play state and title screen
state and these are the components of
our state machine and they are now
instead of being just blocks of code in
our update function there are separate
blocks separate modules that have their
own logic their own update and render
logic and we'll see that very shortly on
line 78 to go down here separate from
that
I'm also instantiating a bunch of fonts
we did this last week so love graphics a
new font takes in a font file and in a
size I've created a few different fonts
here because we have a few different
ways of giving a feedback to the user we
want a small font for displaying you
know press ENTER to start or something
like that we want a medium font for to
display the name of the game perhaps or
I think actually flappy font responsible
for that medium font I think was for
score huge font for our countdown we
want a big font right in the middle of
screen that says three to one and then
we start and then we're just gonna start
off by setting it to flappy font which
is our gonna be our title font so
nothing really new but the beginning of
our UI so to speak on line 92 this is
new and actually this is a demonstration
of a type of naming convention you'll
see often in game code bases we haven't
used it yet but we will start using it
in the future we prefix a global
variable with
case G this lets you know when you're
digging through a bunch of files that oh
this is a global variable okay so I
should probably know it's probably not
defined in this module maybe it is but I
know it's global other things you might
see our lowercase M for member which
means that this is a sort of a member
function or a field of a class and you
can instantly see it at a glance and
know okay if I want to find the
definition for this it looks like it's a
member function so it's probably in this
class here at some line you can easily
find it and so in future lectures we'll
be using more of this sort of G
lowercase G for global variables that we
use module 2 module in this case we're
instantiating a state machine so we're
using the class that we've that we will
take a look at in a second the state
machine takes in a table with keys that
map to functions that will return our
states so we can just call change some
some value and it'll have in our state
machine it'll basically reference that
key in this table here and it will call
that function based on it'll basically
set current the current state of that
state machine to whatever state gets
returned by the function at that key so
in this case change is gonna trigger
return new title screen State and we're
gonna get the state machines gonna be
set to the title screen effectively and
we'll take a look at what the title
screen looks like momentarily on line 96
yep we're changing to title screen on
line 134 notice that we don't really
have much update logic in this
application anymore we're still updating
the Scrolls because this is behavior we
want across all our states no matter
what state we're in we want to make sure
that our background and our ground
scroll so that we have movement we don't
need to duplicate this behavior state to
state this is a global feature of our
game so we're just keeping track of it
here just as we would before but
anything else in our game then used to
be updated can now be deferred to our
state machine class
and when we call G state machine update
Delta time it's gonna look and see
what's our current state and it's gonna
update that state and that's going to
basically be that chunk that if chunk do
this logic that we were doing from
before last week when we had a sort of
primitive state machine line 46 same
exact thing between the background and
the ground because those will always
render scene to scene we want to render
our current active state using our state
machine render function and so let's go
ahead and just look briefly at our state
machine library it's a very simple code
it's actually taken from the book I
alluded to earlier in the lecture how to
make an RPG they give you the state
machine which sort of really cleanly I
think handles a state transition
basically takes in an it and then a
series of states since it has an empty
class or empty table so all of these are
just empty if there is no this is a
thing you can do in Lua which just lets
you initialize a variable if it's not
given a value in your function so self
dot States gets States or some value
which means that if States is equal to
like a falsie value is equal to nothing
just set it to this empty table so it's
just a shorthand for instead of saying
you know if states equals nothing then
set States to empty table self dot
current is just an empty class so our
empty state so this is basically what a
state is it's just a set of methods a
render update enter and exit function
that's a state and then you define all
of the behavior in each of these
functions and that compiles your state
more or less our change function takes
in a name and then also some optional
parameters that we can use to enter that
state when we set the
when we change the state set whatever
are call the exit function of whatever
state we're in so exit that state may be
your function needs you to deallocate
some memory set the current equal to
taking that name and then call whatever
functions there so it's going to return
in that case we saw earlier is going to
return a new title screen state so it's
that's going to be what current is with
self dot current we're going to then
enter that state machine so we're gonna
call the enter function that we've
defined there with whatever enter
parameters we pass into change which are
optional and then here the state machine
update just updates whatever the current
state is and render updates whatever the
current state is as well and so I'm
gonna start going a little bit quickly
just goes running short on time base
state is a all it does it just
implements empty methods so that you can
just inherit this state and you can
choose which methods you want to define
without throwing any errors because it
blindly will call all these functions
not checking to see whether they're
actually implemented and so this is a
way for you to just quickly avoid a lot
of boilerplate code essentially the
title screen state here this is your way
of with the class function class library
just including everything that belongs
to base state so inheriting if you're
familiar with other languages that use
inheritance take an object copy
everything from that object or that
class put it into this one and then add
new stuff to it that's basically what
inheritance is we're inheriting from
base state so it has all the functions
based it has and then on top of that
we're defining an update function so if
we press Enter or return
change the state machine the global
state machine to the play state and then
for the render we're just gonna render
50 bird and press Enter halfway in the
middle of the screen and then the play
state essentially to sum basically what
the play state is is all of the code
that we ran before only now we're just
putting it in the update function here
and the render function here and making
bird pie pairs timer and last why member
fields of the
sort of state object so we'll go ahead
and run this really fast and then we
have this is our title screen state so
we at the very beginning we change to
title screen state all it does is render
and then the scrolling behavior is
throughout all classes all states so
we'll see that no matter what once you
press ENTER it'll trigger a change to
play which will return a play state and
then now we're back where we were before
and we're seeing the difference now and
having a couple of different states so
quickly I'll go through the score update
so this is a little bit more complicated
than the last example but to summarize
in bird oops sorry
Wren bird nine so in bird nine if we go
here we're gonna go to Maine so notice
that in Maine down where we define our
state machine we're gonna go ahead and
also note that we require a new score
state because now we want to display a
score screen down on line 96 score gets
a function or we return a score state
object so now we can change to score and
it'll return that state and we can
define all the behavior within score
state that we need to display a score in
pipe pair we have a new variable called
self scored set it to true or false
we're gonna set it to true if the bird
is gonna pass the right edge of the of
the pair of pipes that'll have the
effect of us scoring a point effectively
because all we need to do is just make
sure the birds gone past that pair of
pipes because otherwise it'll have
collided with it if it does go past it
so set it to true and then add a point
to our score and in our play state we
can see that we've added a point
so if we go to our place date 26 is
where we actually keep track of our
score self not score gets zero and our
place date we're gonna go ahead and go
down to line 56 so for every pair if
it's not been scored yet because we
don't need to calculate this if it's
already been scored it should we should
ignore it in terms of scoring once it's
been scored if the X plus width is less
than our bird X meaning our bird is
beyond the right edge of the pair of
pipes increment our score and set that
pair to true we will then thereafter
because of this condition ignore it and
we're also going to increment our score
so it's gonna be kept track of on 83
notice that if we're colliding with a
pipe we should transition to our score
State now so and we're also passing in
score gets self dot score as a table
because remember we can pass in
parameters when we call change and this
will be passed into our enter function
in our state and then score is going to
equal self dot score we'll have access
to the score within that score state we
don't have to keep track of it as a
global variable to see it in both
locations and 93 the same exact thing
this is collision to check whether we've
collided with the bottom of the screen
if our Y is greater than virtual height
minus 15 do the exact same thing
transition to the score state and pass
it in our current score so another death
condition and then 104 or it's going to
set flappy font and then we're going to
render our score at the top left of the
screen at 8/8 and that'll have that
effect and so lastly here our score
state is pretty simple all it is is
we're going to get from those parameters
we passed in by a change self top score
equals params core we're going to when
we press ENTER go back to play and then
we're going to render you lost and the
score which we have access to
self-taught score and then press Enter
to play again changing fonts along the
way and so if we go back to bird 9 and
then we run this notice that now we have
a score in the top left
and when I get one point and then die
and we go to our score screen now with
just remember we pass score into it from
our play state we pass it in as
parameters and then we can press enter
again go back to play state and when we
fall to the ground we do it as well so
we just taking a look at how to add
scoring to our game but what if we want
to add a countdown screen maybe we want
the users to be prompted three to one
before the actual game starts you know
throwing pipes at them give them the
time to you know sort of get acclimated
we're gonna go ahead and take a look at
how we might do this using another state
very similar to the last example we're
gonna add a new state called countdown
state which is shown here on line 38
we're also going to down in our state
machine add a new key which returns one
of the new countdown States just as
before and then we're going to go ahead
and take a look at our actual countdown
state here so in our countdown state Lua
which is in our state's folder as the
others it includes from beta it inherits
from base state we have initialized a
countdown time to 0.75 this is time in
seconds one second is a little long so I
made it point seven five seconds we're
going to initialize a count to three and
a timer to zero the counts gonna start
it's going to use a timer once the
countdown time has elapsed right here as
this logic shows increase the timer once
the timer has gone past countdown time
we want to go ahead and set it to we're
in a modulo by countdown time so loop it
back to zero plus whatever amount beyond
the countdown time we went so that we
have a smooth track of time we're going
to set self dot count minus itself by
one so that we go three two one
and then if our count is zero which
means that we've gone all the way down
in our count we're going to ahead and
use our state machine and change to the
play state and here we're setting our
font to a font that we've set huge font
and then we're just to string the Lua
function that takes a string or it takes
a number converts to a string we're
displaying self count at 0 1 20
and then our verts in Taft so we're
basically starting at zero y 124 with
alignment and then we're centering it so
the one last piece of that that we need
to change is in our title screen state
instead of going straight to a play
state here on line 15 we're going to a
count down state and what this has the
effect of doing if we go into bird 10 is
when we press enter notice that we're
going 3 to 1 then going into our play
state not just going straight into the
place that as before giving our user a
little bit of time to sort of catch
their breath and then if we die we go to
our score state but once you press Enter
notice we're doing that as well
so in our score state we also are
changing to the countdown state so that
was how to make a countdown state
probably my favorite part of many of
these examples and of this example as
well is adding audio to our application
music and sound effects which really
sort of tie everything together so we're
going to go ahead and take a look at
this it's very simple very similar to
what we learned last week when we even
when we just did pong so in main da lua
of bert 11 which is what we're gonna
look at now we're going to take a look
at a table of sounds that we've
initialized on line 88 we've given them
all keys jump explosion hurt score these
are all sound effects that i've
generated with the BFX ER program that
we used last week if you recall and then
a music track that I found online on
free sound which is free to use the link
is here if curious just a nice sort of
happy sound track that I found for this
game online 99 to 100 we're gonna take
do one additional step before we start
the music we're gonna set looping on
that to true because in games that are
sort of infinite like this we don't want
our music to just go and then stop
abruptly we want to you know have it
loop so play it off our said looping to
true initially actually begin the play
of that music outside of any of our
states because it's gonna be a global
music track and then
that's the music we also need sound
effects so if we do an arbor if we look
at our bird file here on line 45 which
is where we have the logic for jumping
we're also playing a sound of the jump
sound effect that we've generated
additionally in our play state if we
take a look there we can go ahead and
see in our state's folder here go to
play state and take a look at line 58
this is where we score a point so we
should play our score sound effect here
simply put and then the same thing on
line 8281
collide the sound effect here which is
we're actually layering two sounds on
top of each other which is a common
thing to do in sound design and game
design one sound often isn't all you
need to accomplish a particular effect
so I have an explosion sound which is
kind of a white noise effect and then a
hurt sound effect is kind of like a sort
of like a downward like sine wave type
of sound we're doing the exact same here
on 95 to 96 once we put all these pieces
together we're gonna run bird 11 we get
music
[Music]
we get a jump sound effect and it will
make for a point we got a note another
sound effect and then if we hit a pipe
notice that we have sort of two and a
white noise there an explosion effect
layer together so that sort of brings
everything together creatively and
artistically as an exercise to the
viewer in bird 12 in the github repo we
have some code that allows you to
actually add mouse clicks to the flappy
bird in order to make it a little bit
more like the actual game which was an
iOS game so it relied on taps the
function that you might want to use is
loved-up mousepressed XY button and I
would encourage you to think about how
we took input and made it global in the
context of the keyboard and one of our
earlier examples so that we can call
this sort of was the mouse just pressed
in our bird lua file as opposed to the
as opposed to the main file and so next
time we're gonna covering a few new
concepts so sprite sheets so taking a
large file of images and sort of taking
out chunks of that so we don't have to
have a million graphic files procedural
layouts this will be in the context of
the game breakout so we want to lay out
all the bricks in our game sort of
procedurally the way that was in the
sort of the same way that we've
procedurally created a sort of pipe
level in this game well be talking about
separate levels and having them stored
in memory as opposed to just one
continuous level we'll be talking about
health we'll be talking about particle
systems which is spawning little mini
graphics to accomplish various effects
that are otherwise difficult to capture
in a simple sprite animation a little
bit fancier collision detection based on
input so that we can sort of drive ball
behavior away we want to and then also
persistent save data how can we take a
high score and not have it refreshed to
zero every time we run the application
but rather save it to disk so that every
time you run the program thereafter we
can see what we've gotten scored in days
past the first assignment or rather the
second assignment assignment one is
going to be a little bit more
complicated than last week's but still
fairly doable make pipe gaps slightly
random being the first component of this
so before pipe gap is set to a constant
value maybe make it some sort of random
value pipe intervals as well
so we were spawning every two seconds
maybe we want to change that up make
pipe spawn a little differently a little
more sporadically the more complicated
aspect of this assignment is going to be
awarding players a medal based on their
performance so have like oh maybe a
bronze a silver and a gold medal an
image that you display in the score
screen in addition to just their score
just to give them a little bit of
personal feedback and sort of make them
feel rewarded for their effort and make
them strive to sort of get that last
that last medal and then lastly you'll
implement a pause feature which we
talked about in class so that when you
press for example to keep P the game
will stop but unlike that example when
we press P again the game should resume
just as it was in its prior state so
that'll be it
for a flappy bird I'll see you guys next
time thanks a lot